hi in this video I'll be talking about
ketone bodies so generally there are
three ketone bodies acetone acid to
acetate and beta hydroxy butyrate so why
they're called ketone bodies so let's
talk about chemistry basically if you
see all the three structures you can see
a keto group in all of them so they are
definitely chemically ketone and bodies
means something which is insoluble
substance though it turns out that
ketone bodies are highly soluble in
blood and also in urine
so ketone body ketone bodies the body's
term is kind of a misnomer whatever it
is the ketone bodies are important
reserve fuels which are specially used
by the brain in a starved state when the
sources of nutrient is limiting so in
this video I'll be talking about the
synthesis utilization and the use of
kidman body especially in context of a
starved state so stay tuned to the end
of the video and if you haven't yet
subscribed please subscribe to my
channel now in normal state we have
carbohydrate protein or fat in our
dietary input right and different
substances of like these have different
calorific values like protein and fat
has protein and carbohydrate has kind of
a calorie calorific value near 4 kilo
Cal per gram whereas fat has high
calorific value even if fat has higher
calorific value under normal substances
what it would try to utilize
carbohydrate el to generate energy
because it's a easy easy source for the
body right but imagine a starve state in
star state all of the external calorific
input or the food intake is down right
so the body has to rely on its own
reserved source to make energy during
that state so first body would use all
its glycogen reserves and body's main
glycogen reserves are in liver and
in muscle glycogen right so they would
break down glycogen by glycogenolysis
and utilize the glucose to generate
energy for fast few phase but eventually
after when the glycogen reserve is gone
protein reserve is gone now it has to
use its own adipose tissue derived fatty
acids right so the fatty acid oxidation
would take place after all these
reserves are gone and in the fatty acid
oxidation the key ingredient which is
produced is acetyl co a which can be
channeled into various other metabolic
processes to get energy and also ATP is
produced in this process right so now
under the starve state our brain cannot
stop working right and till brain needs
energy even in the star straight without
if we don't provide energy in the brain
the whole body would collapse so the
brain needs energy but the problem is
even if the body try to break down fatty
acid and utilize that fatty acid oxidize
that fatty acid to generate acetyl co a
which can be used to produce energy but
the big problem for the body is body
cannot utilize circulating fatty acids
because blood-brain barrier does not
allow the brain to uptake fatty acid
that's a big problem for the brain right
now
so brain needs some sort of source which
can cross through that brain barrier
reach the brain and can fill them in
absence of glucose so what is that
Reserve will it turns out the reserve
will that we are talking about that
could be very useful for the brain in a
starved State is the ketone bodies the
ketone bodies are produced in the starve
state in the liver and they are
channeled to the brain and ketone bodies
can easily cross the blood-brain barrier
and they can be metabolized in the brain
utilized for an alternative energy
source that would keep our brain going
in a star state so let's talk about
utilization of energy inside the brain
in a normal state in a normal straight
brain would utilize glucose that's
energy source it would
do glycolysis and then channel it into
the Krebs cycle to generate more ATP and
that is how normally our metabolism
works under a Fed state so a satiric way
is one of the most important substances
or metabolic intermediate which can be
utilized inside the brain keep this
thing in mind because we would come back
what happens in the Fed state and how
the body managed to get acetyl co a
where does it get it from because enough
in a first-aid fasted State you cannot
have glucose in the brain right so the
glycolysis and the pyruvic acid won't be
produced so where does the acetyl co a
come from okay let's talk about ketone
body synthesis so kidron body synthesis
the primary site for ketone body
synthesis is the liver hepatocytes so
inside the liver hepatocytes what
happens is the acid lqa is actually
converted to acetyl CoA and under the
fasted situation
griever gets the acetyl co here from
fatty acid oxidation ok now as it turns
it away I mean this process the first
step of the ketone body synthesis is
taking place by the help of enzyme Kyle
lays and then acetoacetic away is going
to be converted to hmg-coa by the help
of enzyme hm request intense further HM
Zeke way it's converted to acetyl
acetate with h mg q li years 10
acetoacetate gets broken down into beta
hydroxy butyrate and acetone both of
which are actually ketone bodies right
and the process is kind of triggered by
beta hydroxy butyrate dehydrogenase this
converts acetoacetate to be the hydroxy
butyrate so basically it's a
dehydrogenase enzyme and if you notice
that one of the ketone group is
basically reduced to alcohol group so
that's the difference between the
acetoacetate and beta-hydroxybutyrate so
these three substances can now be
circulated into the brain and let's look
at what happens in the brain when these
substances are there in the brain
we just talked about with the hydroxy
butyrate for the moment but before we
start you have to understand right now
the brain is deprived of glucose so
pyruvic acid is not getting converted to
acetyl co a so there is a problem of
getting acetyl co in the brain itself so
let's see how brain gets as it'll go
ahead then we would understand so
beta-hydroxybutyrate let's say one of
the ketone bodies is in the brain right
now in the fasted State it cross the
blood-brain barrier and reach the brain
now beta hydroxy butyrate would be
broken down to produce a STL Kawai sopia
hydroxy butyrate it would first be
broken down but with a hydroxy butyrate
dehydrogenase and it would form the
acetoacetate from acetoacetate the most
important enzyme is B Jackie - si weight
transference which would convert
acetoacetate to a c2 acetyl co a and
this enzyme is not present in the liver
imagine this if this enzyme is present
in the liver then it would be a futile
circle cycle right liver makes ketone
bodies and breaks ketone bodies as well
so this enzyme is only present in the
brain so it would break acetoacetate
into acetyl acetone cuvette and further
from a c2 acetyl co a with the enzyme
help of enzyme tile is it can break down
as it was it'll go a to acetyl co a now
acetyl co a can be now channeled in the
brain cells to form like I mean to be
funneled into the sidechick acid cycle
or the Krebs cycle and thereby producing
ATP's and keeping our brain going right
so now our brain would be charged even
in the fasted State so what we learn
from this video so we understood that
how it or not these are produced by
ketone bodies are reserve wheels and how
they provide I mean energy source to our
brain even in starve State when our
brain need energy but it doesn't have
its ready-made fear which is glucose so
we can totally understand that ketone
bodies are good sources of energy when
in in a fasted state when like when
Blucas is not available so that is the
overall message in the video and this is
a very introductory video we would talk
about ketone
would seem this is ketone body
utilization and regulation in details so
stay tuned for my next video thank you
and don't forget to Like share and
subscribe